after this week's crisis summit at
Sandringham it looked like Harry and
Megan were getting the Canada style
transition deal they wanted having their
cake and eating it the trouble is it's
looking like Canada doesn't want them
the country's Finance Minister has
denied reports it will foot the couple
security bill and Canada's biggest
selling newspaper says as long as the
pair remain royal they shouldn't be
allowed to stay here's a quote as long
as you're a member of the royal family
this country cannot become your home
that's from the globe in the mail it's
not something Canada should allow what's
clear is that unlike Megan and Harry
the Canadians respect the Queen and the
institution's she represents and won't
say either damaged or embarrassed their
view is come here if you want to but is
plain old Megan and Harry and deal with
all the fulfilling the work permits the
immigration stages just like ordinary
independent people would and don't
expect the Canadian taxpayers to foot
your bills well it sounds good to me
but as much as they shout about wanting
independence I'm not sure this petulant
insensitive couple understand the
concept I honestly don't see what all
the fuss is about and I'll tell you why
look first of all I think Mex it's a
misnomer and it's unfortunate that
people have decided to make it about
Megan and her views when it's not only
Megan that wants it out the royal family
Harry for years and years and years has
said he only wants ever to be used to be
a normal person on top of that if you
remember the Queen's Christmas Day let
me please complete my thoughts if you
remember the Queen's Christmas Day
address
she didn't include their photo on the
mantelpiece there and there's a reason
for that and the reason for that is
because Prince Charles when it becomes
King once - probably sensibly and
rightfully so wants to streamline the
monarchy and only include the direct
line of succession and so in other words
they were going to be out eventually
anyway they probably jumped before they
were pushed nobody was happy with the
situation
so surely with them out of whatever it
means to be a senior royal everyone
ultimately should be happy you know what
I think this is really about as as
economist Freddie says and for unheard
mentioned recently I think this is a is
actually come to symbolize more of a
deeper struggle and met
struggle between let's call them the
entitled traditional establishment
versus the privileged woke new cultural
establishment and that kind of meta
struggle is what we see playing out in
our media I actually think is a storm in
a teacup I mean if somebody doesn't want
to be a member of a club or firmly yeah
they can see I'm gonna take if somebody
doesn't want to be a member you we
cannot compel people to live a life
they're not happy living and Harry's
never been happy and I actually am quite
disturbed people are making it all about
Megan when when really not able to be
with did you read the Queen's statement
well no I read extracts on it you just
say I'm an amazed you haven't read a
statement because it's very rare Her
Majesty makes a statement like this and
it was deeply personal now listen she
says my family and I are entirely
supportive Harry Megan's desire to
create a new life as a young family
although we would have preferred them to
remain full-time working members of the
royal family we respect and understand
their wish through the more independent
life as a family while remaining a
valued part of my family these are
complex matters for my family to resolve
and there is some more work to be done
but I've asked for final decisions to be
reached in the coming days did you know
get really tired
eight times she mentioned her the word
family in that short statement she's
devastated he's leaving you do not know
he's always wanted to leave them and you
don't know he's very popular he's
incredibly privileged life he's been
brought up as part of the royal family
he's met a young woman who I think has
discovered it wasn't the fairy tale she
thought it was going to be she loved the
wedding in the carriage but with people
waving their flag but I suspect she
discovers when you've got to go and open
a black in a village hall in mirth that
suitable on a Thursday afternoon for
exactly it's not as glamorous she
doesn't like the deference to the Queen
the deference to William and his wife
but that's how it is in the royal family
is hierarchical and she's Norfolk City
to tangle but she's yeah that's not what
I've said to some most is clearly what's
upset to the most is the treatment by
certain sections of me these two
last week on I don't know if you saw it
but I also got a question time they
asked the audience how many of you don't
sympathize with not a single hand went
up Alachua there's a poll this way this
shows that I think it's 26% are against
their decision which means 74% are
either don't care or forward I mean all
polls are selective I think your
particular when you're using them but
but when the real thing is that the
public I think I tend to give you the
one thing that Greg omitted from that
poll is rather staggering 63% do not
think the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
should continue to receive an income for
the dirty war in other words if they
want to give up this life they've got to
give up the money millions a million
which is eight over time they wanted can
I just bring in Harry because we're
talking about what Harry wants I think
Harry can speak for himself as come
Megan and this is why IRA said he once I
go into the cookhouse and everyone has a
good old Corp and that's one thing that
I dislike our being here because there's
plenty of guys in there that have never
met me therefore look at me as Prince
Harry and knots Captain Wales which is
frustrating which is probably another
reason why I'd love to be out on the
patrol bases away from it all
it's as normal as it's going to get I'm
one of the guys I don't get treated any
differently I suspect he's never wanted
this attention well no all I'm saying is
I'm not going to come in on this debate
because I'm a huge admirer of both the
Duke and Duchess and Sussex and I work
closely with their charities so I don't
want to get into this debate but I am
quite surprised by some of the stuff
that I'm hearing that's what
I mean worry will be if they do walk
away from this very gilded life that
your charities they'll know you'll have
to find new patrons and they're letting
those charities to hide the money in the
taxes I believe and if I correct me if
I'm wrong and by the way I had read that
statement and I was thinking of a
different one but I believe that the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex know there
was one when they first announced their
Instagram I believe that they've already
said and accepted that they won't need
the money you know they won't take the
money won't expect the money to come
their way they said they still want the
money from the the Duchy of Cornwall
which is 2.5 money that was a deal done
with the state better come on it's it's
it's it's the personal money of the jet
the Prince of Wales which he's inherited
which the robber barons pinched off of
Lando's well it's person in a sense
until it's Williams money where he
becomes well surely Maggie's point is
the other one that actually which we've
said on this program before they are
going to be less and less significant as
their life goes on as Williams children
grow up and you've seen it if you look
at back at the Queen's jewel you know
and I am I imagine if they if this is
what they decide they want to do then
they should go and do it if it means if
it means giving up the money then
they've got to give up but it's very
interesting that Canada has had a couple
of weeks of the kind of of the exposure
of Jamaica and Harry and this this was
the whole point of my intro I wanted to
know that kind of but I was complaining
about the media newspaper did a leader
which is representatives of people who
read the newspaper and what they're
saying is they do not want to get
involved with Megan and Harry they don't
want them there as Royals at what you
want to happen
well Canada has said quite clearly as
long as they remain members of the royal
family they don't want the land
what they're saying what I want them to
go as quickly as possible
because I think they're damaged do you
overwork can I finish it's just asking
me a question there I think they're
damaging that the royal breath
and I think there's a lot of think
they've lost a lot of public support the
minute they started criticizing the
Queen because they disrespected her they
insulted her they've insulted the people
that's humbling they tell us or we're
racist and sexist so as far as I'm
concerned the quicker they show off the
better